the US is seeing a massive spike in
people applying for unemployment
benefits as the corona virus pandemic
continues to force layoffs nationwide we
talked to economic experts and our own
financial journalists for advice on how
to plan ahead step 1 if you lose your
job file for unemployment immediately
the Department of Labor's website is a
good place to start it lists all the
requirements for figuring out whether
you qualify for benefits next you need
to fill out an unemployment assistance
application with your state before the
coronavirus folks had to wait for a week
before applying for unemployment but
that requirement has been waived so now
you can apply right away the form can be
filled out in person or during times
like these that call for social
distancing you can do it over the phone
or online you'll need some basic
information like your driver's license
social security number and details on
your previous job from that point it
typically takes 2 to 3 weeks to get your
first payment now what if you still have
your job but have been forced to take
mandatory unpaid leave also known as
furlough experts say those employees are
also eligible for unemployment the third
scenario is if you're only partially
employed or your hours have been
severely reduced we found out that you
can still apply for unemployment
most states pay benefits for 26 weeks or
about 6 months the amount of money you
get in that unemployment check varies
from state to state so for example the
maximum Massachusetts pays is seven
hundred and ninety five dollars a week
the highest of any state Mississippi
workers on the other hand received the
lowest unemployment checks at two
hundred and thirty-five dollars a week